F: On se creusait la tête avec Studio Vrac on avait vraiment envie de faire
une vidéo ensemble tous les 3
T: pourquoi je suis en tension?
F: tu as le stress de devoir
réaliser un effet de mentalisme ou
de magie je ne sais pas quelle solution tu vas
prendre
pour mentaliser notre ami
Cyril c'était ton envie à toi
euh.. tu m'as dit à peu près ce que tu voulais faire *rires*
T: je le connais bien du coup c'est un peu bizarre
de faire ça mais Cyril  grâce à
Fabien
j'ai réussi
à prendre quelques petites techniques je
vais tenter de deviner
une chanson parmi une liste que je viens de concocter à l'instant
C: Manu Chao el corazon..
*avance rapide*
T: bon maintenant tu as 5 secondes pour choisir une
de ses chansons
alors maintenant tu vas la chanter dans ta tête
Je peux essayer ou pas?
F: ouais ouais vas-y!
F: moi j'ai ma petite idée
T: je pense
que c'est Daft Punk!
C: Ouiii!
T: c'est pas mal j'ai réussi!
F: C'est pas mal ! en vrai, t'as réussi! Alors nous on va faire quoi parce
que je pense à perdu la moitié de l'audience j'vais tout vous faire le
montage en une minute, au moment où je vous parle on est à 1minute 01 de la
vidéo
T: exactement! et là on est à 11 minutes 30
F: alors qu'on est à 11 minutes 30 au compteur.. alors!
alors on cherchait tout à l'heure un truc
pour ..pour.. pour vous faire tous ça
ensemble
voilà ce que je proposais que toi
tu fasses des choix.. ( Cyril acquiesce)
que je déduise ensuite ses choix en te
posant des questions
et que au lieu de les révéler mes
conclusions j'essaye d'influencé
Thomas
à reproduire les mêmes choix
que toi et après qu'on compare
vos deux actes pour
voir si ça a marché si j'ai..
j'ai réussi en fait à être
l'espèce de pivot entre vous, la plaque
tournante de votre drone neuronal
T: ouah!
F: j'ai jamais dit une phrase
aussi belle, se sera peut-être le titre de la vidéo, ok? *rires*
Cyril! Je t'ai dessiné ici
regardez! Ça c'est Cyril..
tu te reconnais?
C: Ah je vois, un grand corps lâche!
F: Un grand corps lâche
alors j'ai pas fait  la flexion des genoux dont tu nous as parlé mais je ne le savais pas encore à ce moment là
il y a des pieds...
un pantalon... une ceinture... un haut.. ou une veste je n'ai pas fait  la capuche
et un chapeau
tu vas tout colorier de la tête aux pieds.
C: d'accord
F: donc d'abord le chapeau ensuite le t-shirts ensuite la ceinture ensuite le pantalon
et pour terminer: les pieds
moi je vais.. je n'ai pas de capuche..c'est ridicule ce que je viens de faire! Je viens de faire ça..
Ah je n'ai pas de capuche! Bon euh.. je fais ça!
Et même je me mets comme ça!
Cyril: D'accord !
F: D'accord?  Comme ça tu peux témoigner..
F: donc vas-y fait ton chapeau
C: J'y vais d'entrée? Sans que tu m'influences nullement?
F: non ce n'est pas à toi de faire ce petit travail
C: D'accord
F: donc tu fais ton petit chapeau, c'est parti
C: Il faut que ce soit bien colorier?
Fabien: Ouais t'en qu'à faire..
Fabien: Les amis! J’accélérais quand même au montage la phase de coloriage
Cyril: ah mince..
j'ai envie que les gens ils voient mon application..
*Accélération*
C: alors vous allez voir...
c'est extraordinaire
en faite j'ai eu, ça se verra peut-être sur mon visage, un coup de panique
de me dire je montre le truc et là il y a Thomas en face
F: HA HA HA HA!
C: Ouf! Il n'était pas là!
F: tu me dis quand je peux regarder sans risque sans que je ne vois quoi que se soit..
C: attends je la met dans une bonne "camoufle"
C: C'est bon!
F: C'est bon?
C: Ouais!
F: Bon ben c'était formidable! J'ai fait une microsieste.. *rires*
Ah la vache je me suis fait mal au yeux en fait! J'ai quelques questions à te poser
néanmoins euuuuh
des questions..
auxquelles tu vas devoir me répondre (Cyril acquiesce d'un mmm)
par exemple là
j'vais te demander de faire mais que dans ta tête
sans les verbaliser..
C: D'accord
F: là, on peut dire que ton haut est plutôt vert?
et je pense que du coup tu n'as pas voulu faire ça en vert
ça peut se comprendre d'ailleurs
que tu te dises que serait trop simple
néanmoins si t'as pas fait ça en vert
ma théorie
et ne cherche pas à me donner des indices telle c'est que tu es allé
sur la couleur la plus proche du vert
dans le VIBUJOR
juste avant le vert on a le B, le vert dans VIPUJOR
c'est le U en fait
juste avant le vert on a le B qui est le bleu
donc pour moi il y a une forte chance que tu sois allé vers le bleu ici
euh... de la même manière
psychologiquement un homme quand il doit faire un choix spontanée
qui n'est pas forcément sa couleur préféré ou quoi ou qu'est ce
la première couleur qui prendra c'est comme dans la thèse du marteau rouge tu connais?
C: Non
F: C'est un forçage psychologique qu'on utilise pour faire penser à quelqu'un un marteau et à la couleur rouge
parce que c'est les 1ère chose qui nous vienne spontanément à l'esprit
parce qu'on a toujours été corrigé en rouge, les choses importantes sont en rouge
l'interdit en rouge, la passion est en rouge,  le sang est en rouge, etc... etc...
donc il y a de fortes chances, pour moi, que le chapeau soit rouge.
euh... si c'est le cas, si j'ai bon là dessus ça veut dire que j'ai bon sur la suite
en tout cas, j'ai une théorie sur les 3 derniers
puisque plus on avance et plus après moins y'a de choix.
donc... je te remercie pour toutes ses réponses non verbales que tu m'as donné,
bien malgré toi
et... et je pense... j'ai quand même un doute du coup... pour le sweat mais je pense vraiment que le chapeau est rouge
et on verra bien
Maintenant je vais essayer de les retransmettre
C: D'accord
F: Pareil mais sous forme d'influence à notre ami... à notre ami Thomas.
Là maintenant c'est l'inverse, je vais... essayer de te parler
et de te faire faire des choses sans regarder moi même le résultat final
C'est parti.
Je retourne dans mon antre du  'Je Ne Vois Rien'
quand je vais claquer des doigts tu vas prendre une couleur qui n'est pas ta couleur préféré.
Maintenant *Claque des doigts*
tu fais le pantalon s'il te plait, tout le pantalon
T: OK
F: Est ce que tu peux prendre la couleur que tu aimes le moins dans ta main s'il te plait
T: La couleur que j'aime le moins dans mes mains
F: La couleur qui t'inspire le moins, que tu aimes le moins.
tu prends la couleur que tu aimes le moins
T: OK
F: Quand tu l'as, tu l'as débouche et tu fais tout le chapeau, le petit chapeau qu'il y a en haut.
T: Ça marche
*Vidéo accélérée*
F: Tu rebouches et tu poses
Prends le temps de la réflexion de dire le prochain coup "C'est cette couleur là que j'aimerai prendre et pas une autre"
T: OK
F: Tu as fais le choix mentalement?
T: Oui
F: Alors prends là maintenant physiquement
donc là c'était pas spontanée c'était un truc tout réfléchi
T: Tout à fait
F: Et... tu colories la petite ceinture, tu sais juste au dessus du pantalon.
T: OK
*Vidéo accélérée*
T: Je le pose comme ça c'est fait
F: Prends la couleur que tu préfères sur les 2
C'est bon?
T: Oui
F: Tu fais tout le tee shirt c'est ce qu'il y a de plus long
T: Oui c'est ce qu'il y a de plus long
*accélérée*
F: Et tu as compris qu'avec le dernier feutre tu ferais les?
T: Le chapeau
F: Non tu l'as fait tout à l'heure
T: Oui je sais c'est une blague
F: Oh Put*** j'ai eu peur
*Rires*
F: J'ai flippé
T: Je fais les...
chaussures
F: Les chaussures
Et remarque je vais te donner un petit truc
T: AH !
F: Si je ne me suis pas trop trompé dans ce que j'ai fait,
le chapeau et les chaussures devraient un peu se ressembler
*Rire de Thomas*
F: Il devrait avoir un petit air de ressemblance
T: C'est assez euh... c'est possible, c'est possible. On sait pas trop hein...
OK, OK
F: Tu as terminé ou pas?
T: Oui c'est terminé
F: Alors Cyril ne te retournes pas
T: Niveau coloriage je suis un peu...
F: Il y a que moi qui se retourne
T: C'est pas terrible mais...
l'intention est là?
F: OK
C: Alors?
F: Toi tu as fait ça
j'ai les yeux défoncés là du coup
T: Mais tu sais ce qu'a fait Cyril ou pas?
F: Ah ben non
C: Tu l'as pas vu son dessin?
F: Ah ben non, non j'ai pas vu.
T: C'est fort
F: Déjà ce que je peux dire
c'est qu'au moins
Tout ce que je voulais faire avec toi c'est ce qui c'est passé
*Thomas Rire*
F: Tu n'as pas de preuve de ça. Tu vois
mais sache que c'est exactement ce que je voulais
T: D'accord
F: Attends, vas y, on va l'enlever
T: Je te crois
F: Mais ce que je voulais faire c'est exactement ça, alors maintenant
si c'est la même chose qu'il a fait
on peut me croire.
Si c'est pas la même chose tu sauras jamais si c'est ça que je voulais ou pas tu vois
et si ça se trouve c'est pas ça que je veux, je dis ça comme ça
au cas où, ce soit la même chose et ça matche tu vois
Cyril est ce que tu peux revenir avec nous s'il te plait
et sortir ton magnifique coloriage
C: Sachant qu'il y en a 2 où je sais déjà ce que tu voulais faire mettre
F: C'est vrai
C: Et que déjà ce que tu as dis entre le chapeau et les chaussures
F: Ah ce que je disais tout à l'heure c'était bon? Ce que je te disais toi?
C: Oui
F: OUI, OK
C: Déjà ça m'a fait flipper grave
*rires de Thomas et Cyril*
[imite Fabien] Alors je pense ça c'est ça et là c'est ça
F: OK
*Rire de Thomas*
F: A priori
on est pas trop mal, hein
*Cyril ri toujours*
C: C'est bon tu vas pouvoir publier la vidéo
*Rire des 3*
F: C'est ça. On s'est dis en fait, on s'est dis c'est tellement chaud ce qu'on voulait faire
que.. il y aurait une grande chance que ce soit... raté et après... on disait en rigolant on s'est pas si on allait publier ou pas
C: C'est dingue quand même parce que j'ai l'impression de presque pas avoir réfléchi en fait au moment de le faire
F: Ben c'est bien ça qui est intéressant
T: Non moi j'ai senti mon influ, j'ai senti une influence tu vois
F: Ben oui
T: Mais c'était normal.
ce qui m'a fait tiqué c'est que ce stylo orange *cherche du regard le stylo*
T: On l'avait vu mais
F: Ah oui il est différent des autres
T: Il es très différent des autres
F: Oui c'est vrai
C: Et en fait je me suis dis juste c'est quoi cette couleur
J'arrivais pas trop à voir...
C: Oui moi aussi j'arrivai pas trop à savoir quelle couleur s'était
F: Ah oui en fait la petite explication c'est qu'il est mort l'autre jour sur scène
et.. du coup j'ai cherché à racheter... des crayola wash
et j'ai trouvé des bic decolaro
et je me suis aperçu qu'il coloriait plus
T: Il colorie très bien
F: Vous connaissiez Studio Vrac?
alors c'est bien abonnez vous
Vous ne connaissiez pas Studio Vrac alors c'est bien abonnez vous
Je pense que cette influence était assez subliminale
T: Oui parce que...
F: Pour qu'ils comprennent l'intérêt de dévouvrir votre chaine
T: J'espère que ça va aussi bien marché que nous influencez pour choisir les couleurs
F: Mais c'est sûr
F: Il y a à peu près 10-20 abonnés qui vont aller visiter la chaîne
T & C: Wouaaaah
C: est ce que vous ferez parti des...
T: 20
*rire*
F: Une vidéo par jour sur Studio Vrac durant tout 2017.
du 1er janvier au 31 décembre
T: Voilà c'est prévu bien sûr
F: Ils prennent le relais de mon défi
je leur confie comme ça le défi [Mime un passage de relais]
Bravo les mecs je voulais vous féliciter
[Thomas prend le relais imaginaire]
C: Tu l'as pris toi?
T: Je l'ai pris
F: Toi tu l'as pris toi
T: Ouais je l'ai pris
T: Mais...
F: Ça serait tellement drôle que je fasse une passation de défi comme ça
T: Mais du coup nous ça va être difficile, parce que nous on est à plutôt une vidéo par mois
Le prochain sera... enfin le... ce qu'on est en train de faire ça sort très bientôt
F: C'est vrai
T & C: Ouais ouais
F: Court métrage qui sort très bientôt, allez voir, abonnez vous
T: Voilà faut aller voir
F: Abonnez vous au moins le temps qu'il sorte
T: Voilà voilà
F: Une fois qu'il est sorti, tu fais arghhh pffff j'aime moins je pars
T: Et on fera, on essayera de faire une vidéo avec toi  très prochainement
C: sur la chaîne
T: Pour continuer parce que comme vous le verrez certainement moins bien,
moins non pas moins bien mais moins tu court
*Rire de Thomas*
C: Oui moins bien
F: Vous allez perdre vos yeux en 2017.
*Rires des 3*
Si la vidéo vous a plu, comme d'hab, vous vous abonnez et vous likez
Rendez vous demain à 11h.
Tchao !
T: Tchao !
C: Tchouss